[Musique]
tranquillement très tranquillement le
niveau de l'eau décembre centre ville de
fort mcmurray
de quoi tester la patience des résidents
mais caroline boudreau n'en peut plus
d'attendre au congo qui a brûlé lors des
feux en 2016
il ya quatre ans les feux ont détruit
son condo la reconstruction n'est
toujours pas terminée apparemment ses
environs à 80% terminée et puis il ya
quelques jours elle a dû évacuer
l'appartement qui est louée au
centre-ville
j'arrive pas à croire qu'à ça pouvait
nous arriver encore une seconde fois en
date 4 à un autre catastrophe
depuis dimanche mille deux cent trente
structures au total donc des maisons des
commerces ont été endommagés c'est la
moitié de ce qui a été détruit durant lé
foot 2016
demain c'est sous l'eau avec ça va
prendre encore plusieurs mois avant que
le centre ville soit opérationnel depuis
qu'on puisse retourner à une vie plus
normale
et déjà avant les inondations la vie à
fort mc murray n'avait plus rien normal
la crise de lakovic 19 a ralenti
l'économie il contribué à faire chuter
dangereusement les prix du pétrole lundi
après année après année depuis les
quatre dernières années
on y goûte à ce mandat dino qui est
électricien en ville sur les chantiers
il voit bien fort mcmurray qui est l
endroit au canada où l'on venait pour
faire un coup d'argent rapidement est
devenue la capitale de l'incertitude tu
as des idées c'est pas mal au ralenti
le sco valartis et comme mort puis
écoutez cette voie là parce que ça
commence à reprendre du poil de la bête
avec à préfailles que l'on voyait
finalement on pourrait dire la lumière
au bout du tunnel
sa maison à lui n'a pas été inondée mais
avec tout ce qui s'est produit au cours
des dernières années elle a déjà perdu
beaucoup de valeur
on est là dedans les paniers avec son
papa n'est sémalens forrest par des
dévaluations des maisons il y en a
plusieurs qui arrive souvent de maison
peut-être mais là présent même si wendel
de maison et ça me permet de payer ce
que c'est qu'il a sa place
seul harry potter et ses sols dino pense
qu'il peut retrouver du travail que fort
mcmurray peut se relever de ces
inondations et du coronavirus mais pour
caroline qui est enseignante depuis 29
ans au nord de l'alberta
c'est dur de voir une ville dans
laquelle elle a tant investi souffrir
autant
je sais pas qu'est ce qui va advenir de
notre ville laisse quand même positive
malgré tout j'espère que je crois que on
est déjà très résilient et c'est fort
mcmurray ici laurence martin
radio-canada a formés